The prophet Muhammad sallallah.aii
wasallam told us that whoever builds a
mosque for Allah, Allah will build for
him a sim at a house in Jenna. And we
know the great reward that will not only
be gained but rather will fill your
grave after your death. Whenever someone
prays there, whenever someone gives
shahada in the masid, whenever someone
learns something in the masid, yes, that
will be something that you'll have on
your scale.
[Music]
How are you guys doing? Well, by popular
demand, uh Ahmed Albusi, a person who's
to my left and who has contributed quite
effectively, I think in the last video
about feminism, has come back to
contribute again to these topics. How
you doing, Ahmedab?
>> You're starting to make a splash on the
social media scene, are you? Not bad.
Not bad.
>> Yeah. You're doing some training, are
you? And you're doing some uh public
talking and all these kind of things.
>> Dab in a few different things.
>> Why not? You know,
>> got to keep your options open, you know,
dabble.
>> Yeah. Wow. Yeah. You know,
>> um
>> furthermore, actually, speaking of
dabbling, please. Have you What you want
to say?
>> I think uh maybe we should
>> What you want to say?
>> Maybe we should uh address the elephant
in the room.
>> Okay. Um, obviously there's been quite a
bit of uh
>> what some could consider controversy or
>> um a lot of talk about
>> the court the court really the spectator
court really.
>> That's right. On Douglas Murray.
>> That's right. So I wanted to see like
you know
>> well look I mean the thing is I mean I
didn't expect it to go that way. Number
one, I was very disappointed, very
disheartened with the ruling. However,
when I researched the judge, with all
due respect to him, you know, he's a
person who's represented because
obviously before judges do become
judges, they have to become their
barristers usually before that. And he's
represented the MI6, I believe it is. Uh
he's rep he's actually um been part of
an inquiry called the Swedi inquiry
about torturing Iraqi victims and he
rubbished the claims. I mean he he
decided that there was no credible
evidence in his words that any such
torture was happening. So I don't
believe he's a neutral person. Uh and I
believe his judgment was fraught with um
bias and in fact some of the things that
he mentioned in the in in the judgment
bro is absolutely
off topic like he would say oh Muhammad
hijab is a physically imposing person.
Okay something to that effect he's
physically imposing. Well it's got
nothing complete.
No, but I mean what place does such a
comment have in illegal judgment, you
know, and he he'll make things like, you
know, the he's accusing me of lying in
in this instance, and that instance, and
the other instance when I was in this
protest, when I was in Gold's Green and
stuff like that, and it is on issues
which are interpretive and he is this I
would call this jurist credential
overreach, okay? Where he's gone way
further than what he should have gone.
And I believe honestly, bro, this is
bias and I think there's some kind of
motivation which I don't know what it
is,
>> but we're going to have to find out. I'm
obviously appealing the judgment
>> but I think that I made a mistake and
the mistake has been putting a bit too
much trust in the justice systems
>> in the west. Now we've had victories. I
mean you would have remembered very this
very year um we over we overturned a
victory a ban 26 shanken countries etc
etc. We've had victories. We've even had
settlements which we can't even speak
about here. Many many settlements which
we can't even speak about because a part
of the clause is not to speak about it.
But it it's with it comes with the
territory, bro. Like you win some, you
lose some. You put yourself out there,
you know, you go to court, you've got a
person like Douglas Murray who's
>> viferously
a an enemy of Islam, an enemy of the
Palestinian people. someone who was
sitting in Gaza, you know, um when all
this stuff was happening, he was given
privileged access by Netanyahu in the
IDF.
>> Okay. I'm sorry.
>> Which for me kind of just tells you
everything you need to know to be honest
with you.
>> Yeah. To to be honest, you know, and and
bro, look, the other side,
>> they had one of the strongest law firms
in the country
>> which get RPC which get around I think
170 billion pounds revenue a year. We
were operating on a no- win, no fee
arrangement. M and it is what it is. But
we that's not going to perturb us. In
fact, in any event, if this happens
again, we we are now more equipped.
Actually, we've come out with a lot more
learning experience from this to be
honest. Uh I have personally learned a
lot more about UK law. It's the first
time I was a a witness cuz that's what I
was. I was a witness to this uh trial.
It was the first time I was put in that
position. I didn't understand how to
deal with it um in the proper way. But
now I have a lot more experience. It's a
completely new forum. I mean, look, I
mean, I've I've done many things in the
last couple of years. I've done an M a
professional MMA fight,
>> you know, I've done multiple debates,
multiple podcasts,
>> and I've been in the courtroom. So, I
cannot and I will not win everything.
And that's just something that's
>> I think even like if you look at the
life of the prophet Muhammad that there
were even not every single battle was
won. And that doesn't mean that he
wasn't upon the hak. You know what I
mean?
>> It just goes to show that like as you as
you mentioned, you win some, you lose
some. and um and the and the losses if
you want to consider them losses
>> um are uh opportunities for growth and
opportunities for learning. It is this
is now like I mean subhan Allah the
whole DA sector
>> um has learned from this like we have
definitely looked at this case we've
looked at what we can and can't do in
defamation bro like to be honest last
two years we're on this case and if I'm
being honest um I have learned so much
about defamation
>> so much like what what does what is
defamation what is it
>> what for something to be the fam
defamatory. What does it have to be? So,
I realized that there's two elements to
a normal defamation case. There's the
defamatory element, which this judge, to
his credit, although he's completely
biased in my opinion, and his I will be
appealing this um this this judgment,
ruling, whatever.
>> Um he did say that what Douglas Murray
said was defamatory according to common
law. So, there's that element. It's not
enough though. Um and they defended on
truth and they defended on something
called serious harm. Um serious harm is
where you have to prove that there was a
reputational harm to you and you have to
prove that there was also like maybe a
financial harm or a psychological harm
etc. But I I did my own research and I
think that uh the reason the judge
dismissed this particular case was not
convincing and the things that he said
about um that particular let's say
subsection of the law were very
unconvincing and they will be appealed.
I'm not going to reveal what I'm going
to say
>> but I will be appealing them and in fact
I don't think he's going to have a
response
>> essentially it's not over.
>> Oh it's it's not over. It's not over.
And this is not just look, you have to
understand when you go through a
two-year legal battle.
>> Now I am battle hardened.
Now my solicitors are battle hardened.
Now all of the solicitors that are
representing Muslim people are battle.
Now we know this is what you the mistake
you can make. It's like a fight. We go
into we do we both compete in martial
arts.
>> So it's like we do um grappling
competitions all the time.
>> Okay. This guy put me in a kamura or
this guy put me in a guillotine. Okay,
this is how I'm going to this is how I'm
going to avert it the next time.
>> You have to go through this. And the
community must also be patient with
this, frankly, because there's parts
there's elements of the community
>> who want activism to be done, who want
us to go after these people who are
perpetrators of multiple crimes. But
when we do so, and sometimes
unsuccessful with it, they're very
impatient. Well, I'm sorry, but there's
going to be moments like this, and we
all have to be patient together. Mhm.
And the Quran gives us this, it gives us
this injunction that gives us this, you
know,
you know, be patient together, etc.
>> And there's and there's all kinds of uh
verses
>> on multiple examples from the as well.
>> Yeah.
>> Where the Muslims were yanni treated
badly and they had to be patient and it
and again it doesn't represent it
doesn't represent the fact that they
were upon falsehood. That's not that's
not
>> that's not that what should be taken
away from this whole thing.
>> This is
anyway this is not this is man-made law.
We believe that the ultimate law is the
Quran and the Sunnah. The the the the
full uh blemishless,
perfect, infallible
law which is ultimately true and is not
susceptible
to any uh mistake or anything like that
is the Quran and the Sunnah. We
unabashedly unapologetically say so. So
if somebody using common law of the Brit
the British system or any other country
in the world look at something and they
say something is unjust. I'm sorry
that's not a definitive moral statement
and we don't consider it as such
>> and I think imagine like even like
absolute worst case scenario you you get
imprisoned for this sort of thing
>> for for contempt of court or anything
like that. Yeah. Yeah, it doesn't like
again how many
>> got imprisoned
like it doesn't it doesn't go to show
that or it doesn't prove that they were
upon that they were upon falsehood.
>> If anything that's actually almost the
contrary.
>> If they do that to me they'll be doing
me the greatest favor. I'm not going to
lie to you because it's making me into a
historical figure. Okay.
>> Okay. If we wish for brother
>> no I'm not wishing for any I'll be
honest. I'm not wishing for that but I'm
saying that if they go that far
>> then it's now it's it's a clear agenda
you know and it will be manifest to the
society like okay well now you bring
someone in for for something like that
but having said that look I mean we're
ready for anything you know what you
mentioned what he said is that what can
my enemy do to me
>> you know that if you if you kill me then
you make me into a mart you make me into
a shahid
>> and if you put put me in prison. If you
kick me out the land, then it's tourism
for me.
>> And if you put me into prison, then it's
seclusion with Allah.
>> Yeah. So, at the end of the day, you got
to look at things in a positive way. And
the same thing goes with this. Like, I
look at this in a positive way.
>> I I like I said, I've learned from from
this. I've learned about the process.
It's the first time I've done it. I'm
not a lawyer. Like, you know what I
mean? Like,
>> I don't derive my self-worth, as I'm
sure you don't, whoever else, right? I
do not derive my self-concept or my
self-worth from my ability to win court
cases. I'm not a lawyer.
>> So if I win or lose court cases, that's
in a in a sense outside of my
jurisdictions, outside of my role. It's
outside of my abilities.
>> How many court cases have there been
whereby the person who was actually
completely guilty managed to get off
completely got free UI because he had a
fantastic solicitor because of legal
loopholes or what have you.
>> Exactly. Exactly. And it goes back to
that point you were saying about
man-made law, right? Man-made law. I
mean, obviously,
>> it's man-made law.
>> Yeah. It is what it is, isn't it? It is
what it is. It will go back to the thing
that we normally frequently Yeah. get to
in that way, which is objective truth
and subjective truth.
>> Absolutely.
>> And um man-made law is
>> subjective.
>> Undoubtedly subjective. It's not divine.
>> Yeah. It's not It's not
>> But, you know, it is what it is.
>> It is what it is. And um I'm glad that
we covered this point because the do you
know what I I'll be honest. One thing I
would say about this as well
>> is I was quite surprised. Okay. What I
was surprised the amount of right-wing
newspapers
>> that came out speaking about this
Telegraph came out. The spectators came
out again two or three I think two or
three different articles.
>> Jewish Chronicle came out the the
Independent as well. Are you sure?
>> Sorry. The Telegraph. the Telegraph I
don't there were so many of them that
came out even in India some of them came
out it's do you know what I mean
>> you know the headline is oh Muhammad
hijab loses in a court
>> or judge finds Muhammad hijab whatever
whatever the headline may be right
>> who is Muhammad hijab that you've made
him so important
>> like think of the following right you
know if somebody here local imam not and
these guys are better than I am you know
more knowledgeable in mashallah in this
area or any other area but I'm just
saying for the sake of local imam lose a
defamation case it's not going to make
the news
>> people
>> why have you guys spent million pounds
more than a million I don't know how
much you spent on me why are you
celebrating this victory because you
consider me to be a significant opponent
>> and in fact that's flattering to me I'm
sorry to say it might sounds
narcissistic egotistical oh he's an
egoomaniac he's a narcissist he's saying
that but all you're doing by doing this
you're overcompensating this much is
you're assuring me of my own selfworth
going back to the point so he's so
important that you needed RPC
yeah RPC one of the biggest law firms in
the country with one of the biggest
revenues in the country and this many
this much budget you know some of the
greatest probably lawyers in the country
like Greg Kalis and this uh I forgot the
other guy's name Mark Lewis I think his
name was or Bennett whatever their names
are, you know, they were very good and
they knew all the points and everything
is excellent.
>> No, it goes to show that your your da
has an impact
>> and and my da has an impact only because
the people watching this at home have
allowed that to be the case and that's
why I have I'm very grateful to the
Muslim community. I want to say this I
without the Muslim community who have
given me the platform who have stood by
my side and have been patient with me
>> supported you
>> and supported me and I've we've
supported it's been reciprocal but we
are brothers you know we are in a in a
fraternity together me and the Muslim
community we have been able to in the in
the English speaking in the Arabic
speaking and in the world really create
something
and we'll continue doing that we're
building people and that's why it's
important I want to end here as well
>> that don't put all your eggs in one or
two baskets. We need more than one dye,
two dye, three. We need to create so
many dyes so that if one of them goes
down, if they put one in prison or kill
one of them, that the others the other
one's there.
>> This is what part of the reason why I
bought Ahmed Albusi
after, you know, because, you know, he's
starting his own platform and I attest
that he's a he's an excellent asset as
well. Inshallah, we started together and
I want people to my job now is to make
sure that if I'm not around, other
people
>> can carry the the torch.
>> And you've got your handle. We're going
to put it in the description.
>> So, Ahmed,
>> I'm sure people are going to be, you
know, after this, I think after this,
they're going to be going to your
Instagram. Is it
>> Instagram, Tik Tok, YouTube,
>> YouTube, everything. And look, we need
to have so many dies. They have Look,
sorry to put it this way. How many
pornographers do they have? People that
engage in pornography. Is there Oh, we
have enough dyes. Is there is there ever
a time where they say, "Well, we've got
enough like what's that thing called
that they pay monthly for?
>> Subscription."
>> The sexual my something. What's it? I
forget what's called Only Fans.
>> Only Fans.
>> They never say, "Oh, we have enough Only
Fan models."
>> No.
>> They never say, "Oh, we have enough
pornography actors."
>> They never say we have enough actors,
actresses. They never say we have enough
musicians. They never say we but we for
some reason have to say oh we have
enough dyes now.
>> We don't have enough dyes. We need pe we
need duat from every country using
social media
you know because number one if we get
taken out. Number two, if we make
mistakes, personal
>> mistakes, sins, uh mishaps,
um whatever it may be, and people no
longer have the trust in us that they
once did, whatever it may be, some
sometimes we can be falsely accused of
things,
and still, you know, people are no
longer. We need a group of people, bro,
so that the da can spread with different
personalities, different temperaments,
different dispositions
>> and and this in different language and
this part of my life,
>> that's what I'm trying to do. I'm trying
to bring new people in.
>> I'm trying to because I sense that
they're coming for me, bro. And I've
said this, I I told these people, I told
everybody when when the alleged Elon
Musk threats came, I told them this.
Elon Musk came and said, "I'm going to
be funding Tommy Robinson for his legal
battles." He knows full well that one of
the legal battles against me.
>> I can't tell you that me as a
workingass, you know, West London guy,
I'm going to be able to stand up to all
of that in in a court of law and beat
these guys cuz I just don't have the
technical knowledge for it.
>> Mhm. Without the people watching at home
and without our diligent work, we can't
do anything. But the the point to be
noted is we have to spread the da'ah and
have many different da figures so that
if one goes down, there's so many other
figures and so many other people that
people can take knowledge from and
benefit from inshallah. With that, we
will conclude.
>> Hey, you are you wasting your time on
social media again? Your brothers and
sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a masid, a da center.
Establishing a masid to convey the
message of Islam is one of the best
deeds a Muslim can do. There's a huge
need for it in Norway. You know this and
I know this. So that makes the reward
even greater. So give generously and
Allahawel will give you even more.